ladies and gentlemen dental war and
Bruce Willis
when we were asked to present the award
for cinematography we thought the best
way to show you what a great
cinematographer does was to show you a
truly inspiring example of bad
cinematography I'm very pleased to
announce that I shot this myself
we have here is a bad lighting shot
coming in from the kitchen window
there's book a little shaky camera move
there look there's a baby yep
that was a shot of that tile floor there
yeah I want to get that shot now we're
going to cut that the Me's head yeah
look is it open as a baby oh I want to
get her too much in the picture there
yeah hi honey how are ya yeah you see it
very good when I get the baby in there
get there is beautiful cinema talk okay
there she is
shot that night so um well now that
we've shown you what truly bad
cinematography is we would like to
proceed show you some good
cinematography well we'd like to tell
you about these hermit ographers
there are I believe five of them and
yeah if they are right here the nominees
for Best Cinematography are these well
composed gentlemen Peter Bijou who
captured the incendiary images of
Mississippi Burning John Steele who
answer the question what with Dustin
Hoffman look like dancing with Tom
Cruise in Rain Man
Conrad L hall for single-handedly
raising the value of everyone's Beach
property in tequila sunrise Sven Nykvist
who brilliantly recreated frog in 68 and
The Unbearable Lightness of being
and Dean Cundy who showed us what Culver
City would have looked like in the 40s
if half of everybody living there was a
cartoon character in Roger Rabbit
countryside and the winner is and the
Oscar goes to Peter Bijou for
Mississippi Burning
ladies and gentlemen of the Academy
thank you very much indeed it's a great
honor to be here it's a great thrill
thank you very much the 61st annual
Academy Awards will return with Michael
Douglas and
Oh